over the past month we've been tracking
the invisible election all voters
measured in man marked as the party's
change their strategies and now in the
home run for this election the data on
who voters are where they are and their
likelihood to vote really does matter
this was all on display earlier in the
campaign in West Yorkshire
so Wakefield has been Labour since the
1930s but conservative central office
think it's in play they've blanketed
this constituency with tens of thousands
of central office HQ leaflets featuring
Theresa May and today we've heard the
local candidate is canvassing looking
for data giving out local leaflets in
areas they're traditionally labour and a
bit you clip 268 yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes the local Conservative agent on
the doorstep gathering in tensions it's
the first step in targeting voters data
wins elections really we have a voter
relationship software we should feed
feed back into feed back into that and
then they can see in London and they
kind of know what we're doing on the
ground really and they make decisions
based on that this is our math of the
roads which we are aware of as being
canvassed in Twickenham the Lib Dems are
using similar methods to try to win back
a seat lost in 2015 to the Conservatives
we know who the people who will always
always always always faint conservative
we know the people who will be there
know the u-clip voters we know who they
are so we do try to an extent too we
don't leave them alone we will go and
give them the case but we do try to make
sure that we are targeting either the
soft labour of the soft conservative the
local agents here has been collecting
targeted literature from his opponents
not in the prime minister from the prime
minister and they did this to great
effect back in 2015 early in the
campaign the Conservatives sent
personalized letters to postal voters
with bespoke messages depending on who
they think you voted for as you can see
from the special code at the bottom
other parties did similar things that
lib dems here sending letters from a
leading NHS doctor and an ex Tory MEP on
brexit to voters in Somerset
no she's further done in East London
Labour's 2015 policy coordinator John
Kronus admits his party's uphill
struggle to compete with the
Conservatives on using data to target
voters online I'll see you again all
right yes yeah but locally
he's trying in the 2015 I think we were
blindsided by the whole Facebook thing
we were blindsided by some of their
really segmented postcode analysis of
electorates we did a a Facebook post
last night last night around and it was
then advertised solely in three wards in
the borough and it had 10,000 views
overnight from people in the area so
just in those areas just photos there
were three boards and you just do that
yeah we have the capacity to do it so
that's what politicians from all parties
are trying to do Sky News viewers have
helped shine a light on this invisible
election
the Conservatives are all over the web
in particular adverts that run ahead of
popular YouTube videos and they're
principally attacks on Jeremy Corbyn
conservatives are also trying to get to
young people on Instagram and also on
snapchat Labour's digital effort seems
far more about local candidates
promoting their own posts but they're
getting a helping hand from activists
and pop stars for example with this anti
tourism a song hi in the charge the
election war is being fought on Facebook
the Lib Dems are targeting this Facebook
ad at young people with housing concerns
and you can see these ones are aimed at
graduates in the swing seat of bath so
the Conservatives are using higher
funding to blanket the internet with
corbin attack videos the Lib Dems are
engaged in a highly targeted below the
radar campaign and Labour is relying on
the enthusiasm of its support this is
where the election is being fought
invisibly and where this week it will be
one vital Islam Sky News